dubois ce soir c'est ce soir particulier
mais comment te dire je t'aime bien non
je t'aime bien t'es sympa tout ça tu
vois mais t'es pas connu moi je moi je
ne vis qu'avec des célébrités qui
comprend toi tu étais rien quoi c'est
pas cool donc ça m'intéresse pas du tout
alors suis désolé de te dire c'est la
saint valentin
latvala passer tout seul parce que tu
vois d'abord du mfa chine il sait quoi
t'es moche tu es moche il sait quoi tu
étais même pas ça lève alors des camions
ou des voix c'est le jour de la saint
valentin
les sergents peu particulier je suis
magicien et grâce à la magie
exceptionnellement ce soir je vais te
faire disparaître au revoir mon coeur je
te le dis je pense que voilà on est allé
au bout de notre histoire
le quotidien nous à bouffer je préfère
que voilà on s'arrête là quoi on décide
que stop faut qu'on aille faire chacun
notre vie de notre côté pardon n'a
jamais été ensemble
janet par jour du coup c'est facile
d'euros
je vais boire du champagne en tout cas
jean meyer
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation ça me
fait vraiment plaisir qu'on puisse
savoir un peu en dehors du studio puis
bon je voulais te dire pour ta demande
ça me fait super plaisir
mais comment te dire c'est pas contre
toi hein mais je pense que tu es trop
jeune et trop jeune trop jeune non non
non je suis content de faire ça va en
cinq mois c'est pas c'est pas le
problème
c'est un homme que je te dise à ce qui
m'embête un peu oui mon camion qui gêne
en double file mais c'est sur une
passive raison pourtant je me déplace
j'arrive tout de suite j'arrête tout de
suite il faut que j'aille déplacer mon
camion parce qu'il est sur une place de
jeu concède sur une passe de livraison
en fait il gêne donc je te dis à bientôt
ou pas mon chéri voilà c'est compliqué
pour moi mais il faut que je te le dis
c'est le dîner de la saint valentin et
on a un problème c'est pas chez trop
calme et tu vois moi quand je suis trop
calme je suis pas moi-même parce que moi
j'ai besoin mais l'armée il faut que je
m'énerve pour être moi même et dans
notre couple sarah pas parce que je suis
donc c'est pas possible on reste
ensemble on va se séparer
même si c'est le soir de la
saint-valentin maintenant après un verre
bu là je me suis énervé
en fait je me suis énervé celle ci
pourrait rester ensemble me suis énervé
merci chéri
[Musique]